>>> MANY AMERICANS SAY THEY'VE
BEEN DRINKING MORE DURING THIS
PANDEMIC.
THIS MORNING WE'LL HEAR FROM AN
EXECUTIVE WHO MAY BE SORRY TO
HEAR THAT.
IN SPITE OF HER POSITION IN THE
ALCOHOL INDUSTRY.
ANN MEKHERJEE IS NORTH AMERICAN
CEO OF PERNOD RICAR, ONE OF THE
LARGEST WINE AND SPIRITS
COMPANIES.
SHE ALSO KNOWS THE RISK OF
ALCOHOL ABUSE FIRSTHAND.
SHE TELLS MIREYA VILLARREAL THAT
IF SOMEONE CANNOT USE HER
PRODUCTS RESPONSIBLY, SHE DOES
NOT WANT THEIR BUSINESS.
>> Reporter: DO YOU HAVE A
MANTRA, OR IS THERE SOMETHING
THAT YOU SAY TO YOURSELF?
>> YEAH.
YOU KNOW WHAT I DO?
SERENITY PRAYER.
>> Reporter: AH.
ANN ADMITS A LITTLE PRAYER CAN
HELP AS CLIMBING THE CORPORATE
LADDER HAS NEVER BEEN EASY.
>> THIS NOTION THAT NOT
EVERYTHING IS IN YOUR CONTROL.
AND THE COURAGE TO UNDERSTAND
THAT IS REALLY HARD SOMETIMES.
>> Reporter: MUKHERJEE FACED
PERSONAL HARDSHIPS BEGINNING IN
INDIA WHERE HER EARLIEST MEMORY
AS A LITTLE GIRL IS OF AN
ASSAULT SHE SUFFERED AT THE
HANDS OF TWO DRUG TEENAGE BOYS.
>> ONE OF THEM WOULD GUARD THE
DOOR, THE OTHER ONE SEXUALLY
MOLESTED ME UNDERNEATH THE
DINING TABLE.
AND YOU KNOW, BASICALLY SAID IF
YOU TELL ANYBODY, I'M GOING TO
HURT YOU.
SO YOU STAY SILENT.
>> Reporter: DID YOU?
>> I DID.
FOR YEARS.
>> Reporter: WHAT DOES THAT DO
TO A 4-YEAR-OLD?
>> MAKES THEM GUARDED.
MAKES THEM SCARED TO SHOW
AFFECTION.
AND MAKES THEM ALWAYS WANT TO
SEEK PROTECTION.
> Reporter: NOT LONG AFTER THAT
ASSAULT, HER FATHER LOOKING FOR
A BETTER LIFE MOVED THE FAMILY
TO CHICAGO WHERE ALCOHOL, THIS
TIME A DRUNK DRIVER, WOULD AGAIN
PLAY A TRAGIC ROLE.
>> MY MOM WAS AHEAD OF US IN ONE
CAR, AND MY FATHER AND I WERE
BEHIND IN A SECOND CAR.
AND SHE HAD BEEN T-BONED IN THE
DRIVER'S SECTION, SO THE CAR WAS
JUST IN HALF.
>> Reporter: YOU WATCHED YOUR
MOM --
>> I DID.
I DID.
I RAN OUT OF THE CAR.
I'M LIKE, THAT'S MY MOTHER.
I SAW HER TAKE HER BODY, PUT IT
INTO THE AMBULANE.
AND I REALIZED I'M NOT GOING TO
GET HER BACK.
BUT SHE LEFT A SPIRIT IN ME THAT
I THINK THAT HAS GUARDED ME AND
PROTECTED ME ALL MY LIFE.
>> Reporter: THAT PROTECTION
HELPING HER THROUGH A FIRST
MARRIAGE SHE DESCRIBES AS
ABUSIVE.
>> I REMEMBER THE FIRST DAY HE
BEAT ME.
IT WAS THE DAY I WAS GRADUATING
FROM UNIVERSITY OF CHICAGO.
AND I REMEMBER MY ROOMMATE
SAYING, IT'S NOT TOO LATE.
DON'T DO IT.
BUT JUST LIKE ANY WOMAN WHO'S IN
LOVE, THEY THINK, YOU KNOW WHAT
--
>> HE'LL CHANGE.
THERE COMES A POINT WHERE I
REALIZED IF I STAY I'M GOING TO
DIE.
>> Reporter: SHE DID LEAVE AND
EMBARKED ON A CAREER IN
MARKETING WITH RECOGNIZABLE
COMPANIES INCLUDING KRAFT,
PEPSICO, AND S.C. JOHNSON.
IN DECEMBER, 2019, SHE JOINED
PERNOD RICAR.
HOW DO YOU END UP WORKING FOR AN
ALCOHOL COMPANY?
>> I'M A REBEL AT HEART.
>> Reporter: HER COMPANY, ONE OF
THE LARGEST IN THE INDUSTRY, IS
THE MAKER OF ICONIC BRANDS LIKE
JAMESON, KALUHA, AND ABSOLUT
VODKA.
>> I TALK ABOUT THE NOTION OF
TAKING PAIN AND TURNING IT INTO
POWER.
I FEEL LIKE IT'S MY
RESPONSIBILITY TO MAKE CHANGE.
SO I BELIEVE IN WALKING INTO
FIRE.
IF I WANT TO MAKE CHANGE TO THE
THINGS THAT HAPPENED IN MY LIFE
SO OTHER PEOPLE DON'T NEED TO GO
THROUGH IT, I NEED A SEAT AT THE
TABLE.
THAT GIVES ME AN OPPORTUNITY TO
START CREATING POSITIVE CHANGE.
>> Reporter: SHE CAME AT THAT
POSITIVE CHANGE WITH TWO-FISTED
ENTHUSIASM.
AS THE FIRST WOMAN AND FIRST
PERSON OF COLOR TO LEAD THE
COMPANY, SHE BEGAN HER TENURE
CREATING SOCIAL RESPONSIBILITY
MESSAGES BY PARTNERING WITH
RAINN, THE RAPE ABUSE, AND
INCEST NATIONAL NETWORK.
THE CAMPAIGN LAUNCHED ON
VALENTINE'S DAY, 2020, AIMING TO
TAKE A STAND ON THE IDEA OF
CONSENT.
>> THIS IS ABOUT PEOPLE TAKING
RESPONSIBILITY.
IT'S A TWO-WAY STREET.
AND AS MANUFACTURERS, WE HAVE A
RESPONSIBILITY.
AND AS CONSUMERS, THEY HAVE A
IF SOMEONE IS USING OUR PRODUCTS
FOR THE WRONG REASONS, I'M VERY
HAPPY TO SAY YOU DON'T NEED TO
USE MY PRODUCT ANYMORE.
>> Reporter: SHE FOLLOWED WITH
ANOTHER CAMPAIGN ABOUT VOTING
RESPONSIBLY.
>> THIS IS NOT JUST A JOB.
IT'S A QUEST.
IT'S A QUEST ABOUT MAKING THIS
INDUSTRY BETTER.
>> Reporter: THAT INCLUDES
MAKING PEOPLE AROUND HER BETTER,
AS WELL.
>> GOOD MENTORING IS TELLING
PEOPLE WHAT THEY WANNEED TO HEA
NOT WHAT THEY WANT TO HEAR.
>> Reporter: HER ROLE AS A
MENTOR AS IMPORTANT AS BEING A
ROLE MODEL.
>> MY MOM SAID GOD PUT A GIFT IN
EVERYONE.
YOUR JOB IS TO FIGURE OUT WHAT
THAT GIFT IS AND LEARN FROM IT.
STOP BEING PERFECT.
IT'S IN YOUR IMPERFECTIONS THAT
COMES YOUR STRENGTH AND YOUR
TALENT.
>> Reporter: FOR "CBS THIS
MORNING," MIREYA VILLARREAL,
DALLAS.
>> BOY, I HOPE SHE'S GIVING A
GRADUATION SPEECH SOMEWHER